Compton is not working you know it's not
working for our kids
the public schools in Compton California
are failing at McKinley Elementary where
Lorena Bautista is Mania Guzman send
their children only half of the students
will graduate high school and only 3%
will attend college the school is very
low and it's not good enough there is no
communication at all whatsoever with the
teachers or with the principal or with a
staff and that is something that needs
to be changed
Ben Austin is a former member of the
California State Board of Education and
the executive director of a nonprofit
group called parent revolution last
summer Compton Unified released the
results of a two-year audit they had
done on themselves and the the the
results were quite shocking we have
evidence that adults are not being held
accountable for their work nor for their
ethical behavior this culture causes us
to have grave concern about the future
of learning opportunities for students
in the district the response from the
Compton School Board President was just
as shocking for me when we see these
results at McKinley where the average
kid is 50 times more likely to drop out
of school than to go to college this is
not a coincidence lacking the resources
to move or pay tuition at private
schools parents in inner-city districts
typically have few options but when
politicians and Sacramento passed a
controversial law last year parents of
children and failing schools finally had
a reason to be hopeful with the goal of
winning federal race to the top dollars
Sacramento politicians passed the parent
trigger law written by former California
senator Gloria Romero the bill passed by
a single vote in both the Senate and the
State Assembly this is about asserting a
right for parents in California our
right very simply known as the parent
trigger which enables parents the right
to petition their own government their
own school
if 51% of parents signed a petition they
can turn their school into a charter
school
replace the staff or use the petition as
a bargaining chip to initiate a
conversation about change we knocked on
to three thousand doors in Compton just
talking to parents and we found quickly
that parents at McKinley elementary were
energized and and wanted to stand up and
stand together and make history where is
suggesting a charter school because the
charter school said the system they work
is really different from a regular
district school parent revolution
introduced the Compton parents to VL
comic Farland the CEO of celerity
educational group VLK told us about the
moment she decided to leave a lucrative
career in the private sector to devote
her life to educating kids in South Los
Angeles at that exact moment in time I
decided to quit my job and go back to
school and get a teaching credential and
applied to Los Angeles Unified School
District to work as a bilingual teacher
with the only caveat that I would need
to be placed in South Los Angeles for
the entire duration of my career like so
many teachers in inner-city public
schools VLK find the experience
frustrating with the goal of making a
bigger difference VLK took a position as
a school administrator only to encounter
bureaucratic resistance at the district
level eventually while working as an
administrator at the district
headquarters in downtown Los Angeles the
ELCA came to the realization that
attempting to change things within the
confines of a traditional public school
system had been a mistake and so a group
of other Los Angeles school district
teachers and other administrators we
decided to open the first celerity
charter school back in South Los Angeles
where we belong and the rest is history
founded in 2005 the celerity charter
schools are already achieving good
results currently students in all for
celerity schools are outperforming the
district schools the otherwise would
have attended no job I really liked the
way they spoke to me the way they
treated us on December 7th 2010 the
Compton parents made history when they
submitted their petition to this
district demanding change the next day
instead of validating the petitions and
standing with the parents for change the
school district Robo called all the
parents called them in for an emergency
meeting and frankly lied to them they
have been dreading us the teacher has
been yelling on us you know telling
other parents don't be doing this unable
to convince enough parents to retract
their signatures from the petition
Compton Unified decided to take a more
direct approach
they sent a registered letter to all
parents requiring that they come in for
an interview so the district could
decide whether the parents were signing
a petition for valid reasons and and
they said in bold underlined letters
that you will be required to show photo
identification such as a driver's
license which is a not even a veiled
threat it's a threat to undocumented
parents that you shouldn't come in and
they didn't instead the parents took the
fight to the courts the day the lawsuit
was filed parent revolution in the
Compton parents held a press conference
in downtown Los Angeles what is due to
my child and every other child in
Compton Unified School District is a
right a right to quality education so
I'm standing for that right we have this
chance now and the faience
I know it's just begun but the thing is
it's begun and it's not going in and so
the judge issued an historic temporary
restraining order preventing the school
district from requiring photo
identification to validate their
petitions the judge agreed with our
argument that it is absurd to make it
more difficult for a parent to sign a
parent trigger petition than it is to
vote for president in the United States
a week after the parents legal victory
the State Board of Education met to
continue discussions about how to
regulate the parent trigger law
dozens of Compton parents traveled in a
school bus overnight to make public
comments at the
the parents knew they were in for a
fight the day after Jerry Brown took
office he replaced seven pro-reform
board members including Ben Austin with
teachers union supporters and Tom
Torlakson the newly elected
Superintendent of Public Instruction was
one of the most outspoken critics of the
parent trigger law in the California
Assembly
I think it's an understatement to say he
was elected with the help of the teacher
the the CTA of the teachers union in
California instead of moving forward
with efforts to write regulations that
began months ago Torlakson put a hold on
the process saying it would be necessary
to pass what he called clean up
legislation I can definitively tell you
one thing that if no one were watching
if this could all go down behind closed
doors they would eliminate the parent
trigger law they would repeal that as
their goal on February 22nd of this year
the compton school board threw another
wrench into the process when they voted
unanimously to reject the parents
petition explaining that they were
unable to verify enough of the parents
signatures for the Compton parents the
outcome is unclear at best what is clear
is that the parent trigger idea is
catching on currently at least 12 other
states are taking a serious look at the
parent trigger option and in California
the parent revolution continues if we're
gonna be real about it we've got to
acknowledge that it is is motherhood and
apple pie as it sounds it's probably the
most radical political agenda in the
state of California as parents that we
cannot probably give them much but the
most parity thing is education
the hook is very important it's the most
important thing that a parent can give
to their child
you